سمعنا شكرا عزيزي
السيد الرئيس
السيد
والساده رؤساء
الوزراء رؤساء ومدراء
المؤسسات عز الدين
من اجل ان نقوم
بالعمل وعندما دعاني
لايجاد هذه الصيغه كانت هناك اصلا انا ذاك
استهدافات وايضا
ضربات المسيرات همم الايرانيه التي تم
استخدامها ولكن اصابه همم الهلع اصابتها
اصلا
وهذا الامر يفضي الى اثاره الرعب في
اوكرانيا والعالم
الديمقراطيه نحن
نحن بحاجه الى العمل من اجل مكافحه نقص
مصادر الطاقه
واوكرانيا اليوم هي تواجه مئات الالاف من
الضربات الروسيه التي تستهدف محطات الطاقه
اليوم عدد كبير من محطات الطاقه ثم تقودها
كل المحطات التي تعمل
الوقود وايضا
الطاقه الكهربائيه بالمياه تم استهدافها
غرف نوم
من اجلها ان يكون لها اثر كبير وهذا الامر
بحاجه الى مليار ونصف من اليوروهات بعد كل
ضربه روسيا نحاول ان نعيد بناء القدرات
البناء
وفي كل يوم
المهندس الطاقه الاوكرانيين يعملون
جهودهم من اجل اعاده ربطه الشبكات
الكهربائيه هناك حاليا 12 مليون نسمه في
كل منطقه اكياس لا يحصرون على الكهرباء
ان كانت هناك ضربات روسيه زادت بشكل كبير
بس ايام السبعه الماضيه ولذلك فان مولدات
الطاقه موردات طاقه الكهربائيه هي مهمه
جدا
بقدر اهميه سترات المضادات للرصاص
وان ايضا همم
وايضا
الانظمه الاجتماعيه
في حياته صعبه جدا
نحن نقوم باعاده بناء شبكات الطاقه
ولكن
هناك الالاف من الشركات الاوكرانيه
الصغيره والكبيره التي تستمر بالعمل
بفضلها هذه المولدات مولدات الكهرباء
بفضل مولدات الكهرباء مئات الالاف من
الوظائف ثم المحافظه عليها
ونفس شيء بالنسبه لوسائل الاتصال
تم فتح الكثير من الاماكن ايه في كل
اوكرانيا حتى يستطيع الناس ان يحصلوا على
شيء من التدفئه ونحن ممتمون لكل الاشركاء
الذين يقدمون المعدات والاجهزه الملائمه
لاوكرانيا من اجل المحافظه على مستوى
الطاقه الضروريه
ومن اجل المحافظه على
الانظمه الطاقه
كل المحاولات الروسيه
الساعيه لكي تجعل اوكرانيا منطقه مظلمه في
اوروبا ولذلك علينا ان نتفق على اشياء
محدده لا تساعد فقط اوكرانيا على قضاء
فتره الشتاء ولكن ايضا
من اجل دعم كل القوى الديمقراطيه
حتى يتم دحر القوه المضاده للديمقراطيه
ولا سيما روسيا منعها من استهداف المدنيين
نحن بحاجه الكثير من المعدات والمدربين
وتحسين الشبكات ذات التوتر العالي
الكهربائيه ومحطات والعلافات التي تعمل
بالغاز ان الممثلين الاوكرانيين الحاضرين
في المؤتمر يستطيعون تقديم التوضيحات في
هذا المجال
علينا
كويس
حتى يكون هناك تدفئه حتى نهايه هذه السنه
نحنا بحاجه الى
مساعدات طارئه
وملحها في هذا المجال
ولذلك نحن بحاجه الى حل
من اجل تعزيز الجهود في هذا المجال كل
المجالات والجوانب الفنيه يمكن تقديمها من
قبل الممثلين الدوله الحاضرين في المؤتمر
وهذا
سيكلف حوالي 800 مليون
€
وهذا الامر بالنسبه لنا مهم جدا
وهذه التكلفه هي ربما
اقل ااا
اذا ما قررناه
باثمان وتكاليف
الظلام الدامس الذي قد ينشا بسبب هذه
العمليات ان
المهامه وكاله
للطاقه الذريه التي ترسل الى جنين الى
جميع المحطات نحن نريد ان تتم ارسال فرق
وكاله طاقه الدوليه الى جميع المواقع لان
كل المناطق الاوكرانيه تتاثر بذلك
من الذي تاكيد على الجانب الامني والسلامه
والرقابه لتلك المحطات
المنشاوي
بعد استهداف الكثير من محطات الطاقه مقابل
الارهابيين نحن سا بحاجه الى المزيد من
كميات الغاز من اجل التدفئه في هذا الشتاء
ونحن بحاجه الى مساعدتكم والى قيادتكم في
هذا المجال
وايضا يمكن ان يكون هناك اتفاق من هذا
المؤتمر من شان التمويل اما نويل تحدث عن
هذا الموضوع
فيما يتعلقوا بشراء مساعدات تقدم الى
اوكرانيه همم
اخويا 70 جدتي
يمكنه لهذه المساعدات ان تساعدنا على
ادخار كميات كبيره من الطاقه يمكن يصلها
هذه الكميه الى
2.2.5 جيجاوات من الكهرباء وعلينا ان نعمل
ايضا بموجب اليه باريس
من اجل مواجهه التحديات التي تم طرحها من
قبل هذا
الاعتداء الروسيه
ونحن بحاجه ايضا الى منظومات فعاله
لصد جميع الصواريخ الروسيه الموجهه باتجاه
اوكرانيا
الاستقرار في مجال الطاقه
يمنع موجات الهجره الكبيره الى بلدانكم لا
يما ان يكون هناك اي انقطاع الكهرباء لا
يمكن لروسيا ان
تحقق ذلك لان ينبغي ترك روسيا تحقق ذلك
ينبع مواجهه هذا الاعتداء
اعتقد هذا الامر يتعلق بنا وانا اشكرك
السيد الرئيس على تنظيمك لهذا المؤتمر
اتمنى واتطلع الى
نتائج ملموسه شكرا والمجد لاوكرانيا